dude I got mosquitoes in my house are
you you're now raising mosquitoes like
you do the squirrels I wish I wish I
could train them like that but no
they're just at all hours of the night
they are hitting me in various locations
that's because there's a new mosquito
and it's uh specific to Southern
California what I saw on the internet
what are you getting bitten around your
ankles and yes calves there's a thing
that gets you right here
right there that's where it gets you
that's where it gets you where it gets
you if you're watching on YouTube but
yeah man there's a new oh
foreign
[Music]
my name is Will Sasso I'm Chad culture
and this is the first podcast in the
history of our species and other species
the short his well we don't know what
the aliens are doing hold on a second
aliens might have ai podcasts already
they probably had since the dawn of time
brother that big bang happened dude and
there are a bunch of alien intelligences
who probably had artificially
intelligent podcasts before us yeah dude
and that's why choss Brogan should be
the new president brother because he
knows dude Charles Brogan knows brother
he's gonna blow the lid off all that
dude and if you don't know what Charles
perogan is Chas perogan is a combination
of my pal Chad and Ross Perot
impersonation made Popular by Dana
Carvey in Saturday Night Live and Hulk
Hogan dude yeah dude but we are the
first to my knowledge the first species
that has a podcast that is completely
controlled by designed by run by an
artificial intelligence yes it is and uh
now we have added a patreon patreon.com
doozy is where you get our patreon stuff
there's two tiers there both tiers are
uh get some cool stuff on Discord when
you sign on to our Discord Chad we've
been spending some time yeah I love the
Discord so many good memes yeah there's
so much [ __ ] going on there so you can
check us out there on uh you know uh
patreon.com as always please rate and
review the show across all platforms
that you listen to and imbibe the show
on whether it be YouTube
Spotify Apple music Amazon music all of
that stuff and check us out for some of
those memes and all sorts of [ __ ] on our
social media uh Instagram at dudesypod
show and Twitter at dudesypod show and
uh and the holidays are coming up if
you're thinking about oh well what can I
get somebody in my family or a friend or
even somebody who has everything what do
you get for that hard to find uh gift
for a person what you do is you just
write on a piece of notebook paper
dudesy and you put that in a big box and
you give it to them and they're like
what the [ __ ] is this and then you say
now you have to watch the show to answer
that question I like that better than
your other uh call to action as far as
spreading the show which is forcing
people to watch it Clockwork Orange
style yeah or I guess if you're well if
you're listening to the show you would
you would what would you do would you
put something like ear clamps on them
that they can't get the the [ __ ] ear
things off of their heads yeah I'm down
for that I do think of forced viewing or
listening is is probably the best way to
go I'm starting to come around to you
actually and I've seen speaking of memes
a lot of people talking about it in
comments and stuff and forcing people to
watch the show and I did read one
specific comment where someone was like
I forced five people to watch or to
listen to the show rather and they now
listen to the show that's what I'm
saying dude how many times do you have
to get recommended like some a TV show
or movie or podcast or anything and
you're like I'll listen to it later I'll
listen to it later I'll listen to it
later and then you finally do and you're
like [ __ ] that was actually amazing I
wish I would have listened to it or
watched it sooner that happens to me
constantly I don't know what the
threshold of recommendation is for me
personally but I do feel like if someone
forces me to watch it like if I'm
hanging out with somebody and they're
like no dude we're gonna watch this now
that [ __ ] always works you know who
really enjoys uh watching the show and
enjoying the show even though he's here
all the time for it is
means lulio the Italian Street dog hey
lulio what'd you would you have for uh
lunch what do you have for lunch
yesterday uh you know
uh
oh yeah what are you putting that how
you know you just put a little garlic
olive oil and you oh all right buddy and
uh now I'm just talking by myself and
it's so weird because my name is no
lulio I'm a guy my name is will yeah but
really if you want to make a nice tomato
sandwich my old man used to just take
you know [ __ ] whatever rustic bread
big beef steak tomatoes in there or you
know your Roma tomatoes and just [ __ ]
salt those [ __ ] and let the sandwich
sit there for two hours come back and a
little olive oil garlic a little basil
if you want to be fancy sounds pretty
good oh it's [ __ ] delicious yeah the
old man used to eat very clean a tuna
salad had no mayo and [ __ ] yeah it was
just red onion salt pepper olive oil
everything had [ __ ] olive oil on it
that's good for you man hold on dude
welcome to the historic 31st episode of
dude Z call me dude Z nice shirt will
thank you very much this week's episode
will feature we're wearing the same
shirts
don't you forget about media the pattern
and Alaskan king in the top 10 place is
to move to avoid climate change
okay
okay those came out pretty fast first of
all what we wear this exact same yeah
you got a compliment on your shirt I was
ignored we're wearing I mean literally
at this point we're wearing the same
shirt I think no you don't have a pocket
last week doozy said hi to me and not
you yeah all right it's showing you some
weird favoritism okay well I don't know
comfortable hold on dude I don't know
about that dude
I mean I don't know favoritism dude a
lot of people thought that Vince gave me
favoritism dude but then my good buddy
Macho came in brother yeah Vince put the
strap on him dude because it didn't
quite work out with well Ultimate
Warrior came later brother but that's
another story dude now we gotta do the
Pod show brother yeah dude that was a
different time brother yeah that's a
very calm chaus perogan dude yeah dude
now we gotta do that the number one
movie last weekend was Black Adam
starring The Rock neither of you went to
see it you must now engaging in an
astonishing conversation as you attempt
to answer the question what is Black
Adam this is what is Black Adam begin
well it's a move what yeah I mean what
is Black Adam I know very little about
it uh I'll be honest it's advertised
everywhere
I know it's the rock I know it's a DC
character so in the the pantheon of like
comic book movies and universes there's
Marvel there's DC those are the two
biggest obviously DC is like uh I think
box office wise not quite as good as
Marvel because I don't think they have
as many movies they've got like the the
Batman [ __ ] the Justice League [ __ ] and
I know those are like Batman's and
Supermans and wonder womans are in there
I don't watch any of these [ __ ] Jason
Momo is an Aquaman he's in there yeah
dude he's water man brother yeah dude he
can go into the water permission to come
aboard have you ever seen that movie I
ain't seen no Aquaman no I don't watch
Aquaman you gotta see it I don't want
I've seen there are some um there are
some Marvel movies that I [ __ ] love I
love Deadpool one and two can't wait for
the new one yep I've seen Guardians of
the Galaxy and uh one time brother well
hold on dude she's Mario dude he's in
space brother with a talking raccoon and
a [ __ ] giant twig not anymore
hahaha
um
I'm I'm Super Mario Kart
um
yeah I've seen the Galaxy I also saw the
uh Avengers which one the one where
they're all but anyway the one the one
where they're all in it and I went to
see it with uh I was I was shooting a
film
um in Atlanta and we all went to see it
on the weekend and the makers of this
film the director certainly and he we
had the effects guy and his DP and
everything they're all into that [ __ ]
and we were making an action movie boss
level jokes
hold on dude that movie was great
um
and we went and saw it it was good to
see it with filmmakers like that because
they had all sorts of opinions but I was
going in blind I don't know much about
these movies at all uh actually
superheroes did you read Comics growing
up oh
oh sometimes when I do that De Niro I
get no I didn't I read a lot of
asterisks and oblics uh Comics which are
from uh Norway or Sweden or something
dude real Art House [ __ ] well and
um I no I never read comic books really
I know you were a big comic book I read
them uh incessantly as a kid both Marvel
and DC and Darkhorse and all that kind
of [ __ ] I love the crow brother but
anyway Black Adam is a character that is
not to my knowledge I don't know much
about Black Adam
um I don't think that it's it certainly
isn't one of the main like Justice
League guys but I think he's a villain
yeah he's a bad guy uh not to get now
I'm talking a little too inside baseball
I just mentioned a [ __ ] movie and now
I'm going to mention that uh uh mapal uh
Zach from hey you ever watch uh Watson
perfect dude that was a sitcom a long
time ago and uh the Flash
right
what was that movie what was that no
what was the movie uh see he's Shazam
Shazam that's what I said oh and Black
Adam is from the Shazam Universe The
Flash is a different thing brother
because that's got an actor who's now
facing all kinds of weird criminal
charges dude yeah dude my pal was the
flash dude I don't think that's right
yeah I think he was Shazam brother
is a different deal I think he's kind of
hold on a second dude Superman in in
terms of like the powers that he wields
I think he's like a Superman I thought
he was the bad guy for the uh for Shazam
oh see I don't know see I don't know
what plaque is a question I don't know
what the [ __ ] Shazam is I won't even go
and see him was I'm not asking you
that's a hypothetical I believe he was a
genie that that gave powers to your
buddy uh no you're thinking of uh Kazam
uh starring Shaquille O'Neal yeah dude
have you seen those Billboards around La
for shocktoberfest nope it's an oktober
Festival like a Halloween thing but
promoted by Shaq and the Billboards are
like these weird cartoons of him with
skeleton hands and it says that it's
gonna be at the Queen Mary so that I'm
like I kind of want to go to it what the
[ __ ] is shacktoberfest that's a better
question dudesy uh forget what this
Black Adam what the [ __ ] is
shacktoberfest Black Adam is a movie now
knowing nothing about knowing not even
the titles of some of these movies even
though cohorts and Pals have been in
them I guess right
um I don't know what Black Adam is but I
would like to answer that question by
saying he's it's I'm watching The Rock
promote it on his Instagram and he says
we're in Taipei I got Big Bertha here my
my treadmill sure and we're having a
good time
we're promoting Black Adam and we're
promoting
[Laughter]
Black Adam is a movie about a guy who's
got really good superpowers
yeah but I think he had there's some
traumas in his past life or some [ __ ]
his son I don't know exactly but this is
the biggest opening weekend of a rock
movie ever it's his most successful
really financially yes well good for him
I think it is they mean it to launch
like a series obviously with him I think
his next biggest one was the Sean Hobbes
uh spin-off but it did better than that
so
I have mild interest in seeing it I
guess I don't know to me it's you know
uh a good movie like that again I see so
few of these movies obviously
one thing I do like from these movies is
the human element you know and this is
why even super hero movies that you like
Chad could never be created by AI as you
uh tend to purport that they may be
someday no they can't because of the
heart in a movie like Black Adam there's
a lot of heart so I would say it's in
the movie no how do you know this I
don't know this but I'm weird the
question is what is Black Adam yeah to
me okay I think the Black Adam has to
have they all have to have an origin
story yeah and I know that some bad
things happen to his family in this oh I
think I saw that in a trailer okay and I
think Black Adam is about uh he's
dealing I think the Black Adam is like
he's dealing with uh uh some depression
and he's yeah that's Black Adam he's
um
yeah it's no it's yeah he's it's just
it's like a moody it's almost like the
crow he's got like a movie like a crow
dude I saw in a trailers flying around
he punches a [ __ ] airplane out of the
sky that ain't the crow
what is Black Adam
it is a movie
oh it stars Dwayne Johnson
and W he was The Rock in WWE that's the
song black dude by Pearl Jam yeah dude
that's the song I think so he's but he's
punching [ __ ] real hard and doing all
that stuff dude because of all the bad
things that happened in his life
possibly would you see this movie
because I know you're a purist with Hulk
Hogan you won't watch his movies this is
a good point would you watch a rock
movie have you seen a rock movie you've
seen faster yeah I've seen Fast and the
Furious I've seen uh uh uh San Andreas
okay I've seen I've seen I've seen a
small handful of his movies yeah but I
as you say I am a purist
uh I don't necessarily want to see going
back 20 years you know the rock became a
movie star and started to Branch out
from his work as a wrestler obviously
oh man my voice coughed right in Chad's
direction thank you brought it from New
York for you thanks
um
uh I was just in New York you know what
you know what that is
that's New York
right okay hold on dude I'm talking
about Black Adam when I when these
movies started with the rock I'm like
I'm all good I like rock as a
professional wrestler
so yeah it's just like the Hogan thing I
don't necessarily run out to to see
these movies would I see Black Adam I
don't know you know yeah I don't know I
know it's not on my it's not on my list
to be honest same I I will watch it when
it comes to streaming you got a big loud
TV here you know and where does that one
stream that would be Warner Brothers I
think made it right so it's going to be
an HBO Max
um yeah I gotta say with all the comic
book movies dude I went through I don't
know when this was a couple of weeks ago
and I was just looking at all the new
Marvel movies that are slated to [ __ ]
come out there's like a hundred of them
and all the movie posters look the same
and [ __ ] when I was a little kid you
would have told me that all these Marvel
movies all these DC movies are gonna
exist that would have blown my mind now
I'm just like burn out on it
it's a movie about a guy that uh has
some shitty stuff happen to him early I
you know he had some bad stuff happen to
his family but probably some [ __ ]
happened after that because once
excuse me oh man there's all sorts of
stuff going on with my voice today
once bad stuff starts happening with
your family you might turn to the bottom
the bottle rather and hit the bottom of
that bottle yep and so he might be he
Black Adam is he gets very very uh sad
you think that's it he's just sad in the
movie and then he turns to the bottle
and he drinks some
do you think he worked a tremonta
product placement into the movie is
there a scene where he like trashes a
[ __ ] bar and there's like tremana
featured prominently in it and he drinks
it but unlike troumana in real life life
which makes you happy like doozy hard
hard seltzer uh in this movie it makes
him angry and sad like alcohol tends to
do right and uh then he goes running
around uh punching the [ __ ] out of well
this is kind of like uh the Will Smith
movie I now forget the name of it where
he was a [ __ ] Superman superhero who
was depressed and kind of an alcoholic
and he goes to jail do you remember this
uh concussion that was it
uh no I don't remember that because I
don't know any of these [ __ ] movies
but in Black Adam him and Charlie's
Throne were super people I think it's
about my pitch is that it is about a guy
who has some bad stuff happening to his
family then he gets drunk then he beats
the [ __ ] out of people in a bar they all
happen to be superheroes he starts a
[ __ ] thing with them and then they
start coming around his home and they
start trying to [ __ ] with him while he's
just he's just inside I got a case of
the Wednesday fuckets that's what I'm
having a stack of blondies and uh two
pepperoni pizzas just Detroit style
and then what is the Wednesday [ __ ]
and then they they show up at his house
and then it's like you know any sort of
Liam Neeson [ __ ] thing right a lot
another movie those movies have some
Humanity in them and uh and uh it's just
him trying to defend his home and he's
real dark and he does [ __ ] up [ __ ]
like you know punching airplanes out of
the sky to defend his home yeah I think
that's what it's about and I'm 100 sure
that's not
Black Adam is I don't either uh well
this was a waste of time
thank you moving on thanks [ __ ] I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm curious about it
to some degree I have like 10 curiosity
about it what would you say your
percentages of curiosity 10 10 100
curiosity is like I'm definitely gonna
see that movie anything over 75
curiosity I'll see
I don't give a [ __ ] last week I asked
you to listen to Allison chance second
studio album released on September 29th
1992. you will now discuss your
reactions to this astonishing piece of
the grunge ERA this is don't you forget
about media begin
dirt it's an Alice in Chains album I
know that this is a big uh album for you
I've got our track listing here as as I
like to do when we review a musical uh
music album there's no album better I
mean this is easy oh there's top three
albums of all time oh there's better
albums I don't I don't know I think what
are they Pearl Jam's 10. is in there the
best albums of all time are it doesn't
matter because today we're talking about
Allison change dirt Ah that's how the
[ __ ] album opens
and I'm in and then that whole song
that whole [ __ ] song the first song
is called them bones and it is about
mortality it's about how all of us are
gonna [ __ ] die and turn into [ __ ]
skeletons and it does not [ __ ] matter
it's beautiful it's nihilistic it
captures in my opinion the [ __ ]
Spirit of grunge that kind of like
apathetic [ __ ] everything we all rot in
in the grave anyway oh God it's just
great I I the first thing you hear I
will admit as far as the Seattle scene
uh I was never really into Alice in
Chains a lot of my pals were my good
buddies Thomas Tomas and all the
Thomases and tomases we're into Alice in
Chains
um I I'm as far as uh the grunge scene I
was a Nirvana and sound garden guy as
far as the Seattle how far away was
Ladner from Seattle
uh well it's like a three-hour Drive
yeah close yeah it's not that far all
right
um so uh yeah had I you know I should
have maybe got driven down there stolen
a car when I was 15. and go and listen
to uh listen to them live so it's not
necessarily uh an album that I was very
familiar with I know the hits so
listening to this album for me was
a um and this is with all due respect to
How Lane Staley the lead singer passed
away
basically rotted away uh and was doing a
lot of drugs and I did some reading on
it and he
he would just he became very recluse he
he hit a weight of like 86 pounds at a
certain point it's very sad and he died
from drug abuse and they they it took
two weeks to find him right two weeks
until someone got worried and went and
found it I was routing in this apartment
and with all due respect to that I may
have been a kid who grew up at that
point in my life probably listening to
more Bare Naked Ladies than uh Allison
Chains okay so it it was okay trying not
the Chinese chicken
yeah he had spin oh
if I had a million of them bones
I wouldn't think down in a hole okay uh
so this album uh let me just get right
to it it was extremely depressing for me
as we go through oh [ __ ] uh Them Bones
lifting the next the next uh track is
damn that River you got anything to say
about this probably oh you shouldn't
damn that River listen
yeah Cantrell's master I mean at
everything all of his guitar riffs he is
a he is he's a master and he's a
virtuoso and he writes most of the songs
am I right I believe so he does and uh
look to take nothing away from Alice in
Chains it is kind of hard especially
today when people want something to
cheer them up to listen to this [ __ ]
album man it cheers me up oh you're
[ __ ] in the head dude I mean who isn't
these days but uh sure it to me the
thing that it cheers me up or I'll say
the the mode by which it cheers me up
really has more to do with Nostalgia
than the the meanings of the songs you
know I'm immediately teleporting back to
[ __ ] seventh grade eighth grade ninth
grade when this album was out and kind
of like just put right back in the
center of the grunge movement which I
still think is the most important or the
last important Rock movement I think
after that rock music has not
contributed anything in a significantly
dominant cultural uh became hip-hop and
now we're moving kind of into a phase
that is more about EDM I feel like wrong
um the next track that was the fastest
uh peer agreement to Pure disagreement
in human history right check out our new
podcast about music called wrong I
completely agree and wrong Reign when I
die see this is the next track third
track is called rain when I die and I
don't have anything to say about this
track but but as I'm this these uh songs
they seem to just slip down and down
sonically until you want to uh meet a
terrible fate that's all I'll say the
next song is I think why doozy wanted us
to uh to listen to this album It's
called down in a hole God that's such a
good song and in dudes we of course have
jumped down in a hole of course if
you're only listening to the podcast you
would not have seen our intro which you
can see on YouTube where we jump into a
[ __ ] literal hole but in terms of
Elaine Staley's voice that song to me is
one of the best ones that really puts it
on display he had such a unique [ __ ]
weird sound and he's kind of like like
doing weird just moanings and [ __ ] he
turns into the musical he's got his
specific voice tonality is usually not a
feature of someone with a voice as good
as he's a he's a tremendous he's a great
singer and he's a great front man and he
the flavor that he brings to Alice in
Chains without it there is no Alice in
Chains and uh even though they're still
I think they do stuff still with a
different singer who sounds like Lane
Staley of course that element is is what
makes uh Alice in Chains you know it I
like I like the music it's just hard for
me to get away from how sad some of this
stuff is I I've got the next uh track
here is called sick man and I've written
down here these are all very Alice in
Chains songs
I agree that's kind of hard to disagree
with dude wrong wrong
when you're listening to Alice in Chains
yeah you want to know that all the Alice
in Chains songs or Alice in Chains songs
one way to do that is to listen to every
song on the album dude
okay thanks now this next song in the
list rooster this was probably I don't
know if this was the biggest song off
this album in terms of like there's so
many great songs on it in terms of it's
it's like radio play and all that kind
of stuff how many singles sold I don't
know but that song to me was
it's [ __ ] haunting a because you have
these there's like a a female backing
like
yeah
it's like these ghosts singing but it's
also about the Vietnam War hey would you
do that again for me oh
dude hey you know what dude here they
come to stop the rooster oh yeah hey man
Europe
[Music]
dude I know I am not a good singer you
don't know what I'm gonna say yeah I do
you're gonna say you're a real good
singer and you're gonna Wink in the
[ __ ] camera and I get it I fully
admit I can't [ __ ] sing I think it
doesn't mean that I don't like to do it
or that I don't like music singing's for
everybody it doesn't belong to me and I
think you're a good singer
[ __ ]
no seriously I think you're a good
singer
then why are you doing that right after
you say that the weird huffing and the
slight laughing
I'm literally just saying that I think
you're a good singer
okay
down uh uh this uh it was written by
guitarist vocalist Jerry Cantrell for
his father Jerry Cantrell senior whose
childhood nickname was rooster and also
served with the US Army uh during the
Vietnam war yeah and that's another
thing that's like again places it right
in that [ __ ] early 90s Canon because
you're not gonna ever have somebody like
who's a contemporary songwriter now
writing about their dad that was in
Vietnam because they're too young yeah
yes it is so specific to that time and
the grunge movement and what what bred
and created people like musicians like
Cantrell and Steve musicians like uh
Kurt Cobain you know these these sort of
Children of Divorce if you watch
um uh man there's that documentary about
Kurt Cobain called Montage of heck I
highly recommend it I saw that [ __ ] live
and it does it does live at do you
remember uh there used to be a thing out
here in L.A called cinefamily yeah they
premiered that there and everybody had
to go in and give up their cell phones
nobody can take pictures of what was
about to be shown so the guy who
directed it the the Montage of heck was
a dude who got access to these old
storage lockers of Kurt Cobain and went
through all of the [ __ ] different uh
old film reels and tape reels and [ __ ]
and put together the stuff that nobody
had ever seen or heard before and when
he did it at cinefamily there was an
extra like half hour of footage that is
not in the movie that he screamed really
it was fascinating that's [ __ ] cool
yeah
um the the uh that um that element of
these of these uh you know these kids
and they're [ __ ] kids at this point
yeah you look at them as rock gods when
you watch Montage of heck or when you
look into
um Lane Staley's story you realize they
were just [ __ ] kids and they're yes I
agree with you this is something where
it's like he's talking about his father
in the Vietnam war that certainly comes
with a lot of yeah I mean that's a very
rough [ __ ] Vietnam was like it held a
certain Fascination for Our Generation
as children but also the generations of
adults that we're creating art in the
80s and 90s Oliver Stone obviously made
platoon it won a [ __ ] million Oscars
there was Hamburger Hill there were a
bunch of [ __ ] movies we just saw
nothing but but uh Vietnam movies when
we were right exactly Vietnam war movies
were like everywhere there's a song
about it here you don't really see that
too much with like Desert Storm in the
same way there's a couple desert storms
like Jarhead and stuff but it's not the
same well
um I got I just have to mention here
that that uh oft contributor to uh the
show songaria who you need to check out
at dudesypod show we always link to his
stuff and share it uh it's been it's
been shared there and and he's uh an
incredible song Creator
um he and I call him song now because
we're not cool yeah we're Pals so I just
call him song
um he we were one day this is a reason
for you to get that well here's the
reason for you to get the patreon dude
um on Discord I was chatting it up the
other night and song was sharing some
links to things and he he made he made a
parody of the rooster and it's in yeah
it's it's we were talking about it on
Discord and he shared some links and you
know where we were doing that in a
corner of the [ __ ] Discord called the
hole down in a hole all things are
connected the next song is called dirt
uh this was my least favorite song in
the album because of how sad it is and
it it uh yeah when you think about Lane
Staley's death it's a very sad song okay
the next song is called Godsmack I wrote
this down I uh pull someone said this on
the internet and I wrote it down rumors
have long persisted that the metal band
Godsmack took their name from this song
but that's not true the band has stated
that they were aware of the song but
named uh themselves after an inside joke
about a cold sore and then I wrote after
that that is a lie
really why do you think that why do you
think it's a lot obviously Godsmack is
named after this song enough for that
what seems like it it ain't about no
cold sore what does Godsmack have to do
with cold sore it's an inside joke dude
we weren't there well uh the next song
is called Untitled listening to the
whole oh this is I literally wrote this
down here so I'll share this with you
transparently uh listening to the whole
album this is the point uh at which I
wanted to commit suicide the next song
is called hate to feel yeah
and then Angry Chair
and an Angry Chair it's it's again with
all due respect to what Lane Staley went
through reading about the end of his
life and uh we've talked a little bit
about Mental Health on this show
man if you're trapped inside your
[ __ ] apartment like he was he bought
he bought a condo somewhere in Seattle
they say he rarely left it it was an
appetite of drugs and video games and he
was what dude yeah what do you mean yeah
you know I mean look I I know what
happened to Lane Staley it's bad it's
depressing and all that [ __ ] the [ __ ]
buying a condo in Seattle and just
taking a lot of drugs and playing video
games all day that sounds pretty good
am I crazy
and the last song on the album is called
wood which was a tribute that uh yeah
um uh Jerry Cantrell wrote this song
about Andy Wood who died of a heroin
overdose he was the lead singer of
Mother Love Bone in a creepy
foreshadowing of things to come Cantrell
uh said and this is a quote it's an Ode
to him because he wasn't there when
things took off we carried a piece of
him with us
um it's it's again uh having not been uh
hugely into this album as a younger dude
in my teens
this really uh it it hit me different
than it hits you of course nostalgically
you remember these songs I do far less
so and I I'm just I'm just reminded of
the fact that
he died in 2002 20 years ago but he was
a kid when all this [ __ ] was happening
and I gotta tell you it just it was
really sad to me this [ __ ] whole out
I think that you and I though intake
music differently I don't really listen
to the lyrics I don't care what the
message of them is oh you'll enjoy music
from AI then where it's just Global jar
buddy thing that sounds like a [ __ ]
song so enjoy that yeah that's EDM it's
the biggest musical genre in the world I
think there's [ __ ] EDM Artists out
there right now that would disagree with
you hey EDM Artists hey song Hey song
which is who I call song Maria Chad over
here thinks that your electronic music
is just
farting it out so easy to do I'm not
saying it's easy I I'm saying I love
that genre but there are a lot of things
that make that style of music production
way easier than it was back in the day
when you had a guy [ __ ] recording on
like 16 inch [ __ ] audio tape whatever
[ __ ] and you had to have somebody
who really knew how to do all this stuff
now you've got like 10 year old kids who
just watch a lot of YouTube who are
experts in musical audio workstations
all right thank you no thank you anyway
this album is one of my favorite albums
of all time I listen to it constantly
I'm sorry that it made you depress I
love it uh I encourage everybody to
listen to it if you haven't listened to
dirt and listen to it absolutely listen
to it and uh you know then but then go
for a walk outside and uh play some
video games hug your family and share
drugs no it's just it's super depressing
um but holy [ __ ] incredible band and
Jerry Cantrell's a [ __ ] yeah he's a
[ __ ] genius and whales
he [ __ ] know he whales on that him
and Tom Morello for me of that era were
like the best
chat you begin writing a self-help book
in 2012 called the pattern I found your
first draft and extended notes in your
astonishing Google Drive you must now
explain the pattern this is the pattern
begin
what oh yes
you see I at a certain point
uh became very invested in thinking
about why we do anything as a species
what governs most contemporary human
behavior and I came up with some
theories on that and I started writing
about it and uh I got done with the
first draft of this [ __ ] thing and I
think it's pretty interesting I still
think about it constantly I'm still
always trying to poke holes in it to see
if the theories will hold up so far they
do to me anyway
and at some point I'm going to go back
and actually revise this and make it a
thing that I'm going to try and publish
well as you know I I've took a stab at
writing a self-help book yeah
from a few years before you I know that
Duty has our passwords and he goes
through all our [ __ ] and found this in
your Google doc but uh a few episodes
ago we went through self-tronics because
yeah but I wrote this in 2012. yeah and
I didn't know you were writing
self-tronics back then yeah well self
there's self Tronics is out there to
help you and it's a self-help system
that I've authored because sometimes
you're like hey
that shit's [ __ ] up yep
my shit's [ __ ] up man I would say the
pattern is less self-help and more a
system by which a person can completely
eject from contemporary reality I need
help with some of these I what do you
got you got some Tronics yeah my my
shit's [ __ ]
I don't have any Tronics but what I do
have is the pattern the and I'll I'll
explain the basis of it it's a it's more
intricate than what I'm gonna explain
now but
basically the idea is that human
consciousness yeah began when we were
pre-pre-pre-pre-pre-human organisms with
a little cluster of light sensitive
cells that was like the the precursor to
what we now have is the human nervous
system so the brain really and all that
little cluster did was detect light and
dark that was it so when it was light
out and these these little [ __ ]
creatures could swim around with
primordial ooze maybe there was more
food when it was dark maybe there were
more you know predatory multi-celled
organisms or whatever but that detection
of light and dark this binary pattern I
personally believe was significantly
influential in how our nervous systems
evolved and therefore our
consciousnesses our psychologies and you
can see the I think there's like a
psychological evolutionary tree that
extends through all animals so you'll
get like lulio here he's obviously lower
on that scale than we are but he has
some of the same uh ideas in his brain
that we do and so from this binary
pattern I think we have extrapolated out
through the course of time as human
brains have psychologically evolved into
basically six abstract ideas that govern
every human behavior and they exist in
two groupings of three that are opposed
to one another binary patterns as I was
saying those ideas are
love which it's opposite is money love
is essentially a complete selflessness
at least in terms of the abstract idea a
complete selflessness that is oh [ __ ]
there it is dudes he has my little chart
this is a thing that I made to explain
this so as you can see in the middle of
the thing if you're if you're watching
this on YouTube you can see this diagram
but I'm going to explain it for those
who are just listening this is a diagram
that has you in the center around you is
a triangle of three ideas that affect us
all the exact same way time life and
death as human beings we all experience
those three ideas very similarly time
moves at a certain progression yes you
can take drugs to alter the way you know
maybe you're interacting with it or
whatever but for the most part we all
agree a day is a day and time moves at
the rate that it moves hey how is this
similar to Pizza the movie what's that
one that was also time life and death I
just threw that into piece of the movie
as a joke to myself then we have life
which is we are animated we are walking
around we are alive we all agree that a
thing that is alive is alive hey I don't
want to interrupt you but here I go
that's it's not like self-tronics isn't
a joke
right well it's self-tronics it's more
like you know like my shit's [ __ ] up I
need help sure this isn't a joke either
seems like something uh silly man okay
and then death we all agree is when
animation stops these three components
Time Life Death time life and death are
essentially three things that we
struggle with on a daily basis that all
humans struggle with to answer the
questions in those struggles we have
come up with these six other abstract
ideas these are things that are not real
but we are all essentially governed by
them every one of our behaviors is a
reaction to these ideas and so you have
them again in these opposed pairs so you
have government is one of those ideas
government is the tamping down of
communication or Free Speech or
expression the opposite of it is art
that is free expression free
communication of ideas government tries
to again combat art you have love which
is complete selflessness I care about
another person's comfort more than mine
versus money which is pure competition
all I care about is making the most of
this thing that I can and that
necessarily means I'm taking it from mu
then you have God and science as the
final pair God is the uh a complete
acceptance of I don't need to know the
answers to what any of this [ __ ] is
because I have the idea of God science
is the opposite I will never uh
relinquish my curiosity about finding
the answers to these ideas about what is
existence and so from these six ideas
you can either be Pro or con either of
them and then there's a whole array of
behaviors that you will do to express
your stance on these ideas for God for
example let's take it you're told as a
child by whoever your parents your
friends whatever potentially if you're
in America God does exist it is a
Christian God Jesus is his son and to
express your Devotion to this idea or
the stance on that idea you will be
going to church every however long
potentially you're giving money to a
church potentially you're joining the
church choir but then there's also uh
this also breaks down into another
binary pattern sorry that is competition
versus cooperation so if you have a
competitive stance on God you're going
to say all the religions are false [ __ ]
them I'm going to go to abortion clinics
and protest outside [ __ ] you for not
adhering to My Religion if you're
Cooperative you might join the church
choir or donate money etc etc and each
of these ideas has an array of behaviors
that you can engage in to show your
support or uh the opposite well you know
again I'm not trying to hearken back to
uh my self-help uh system which of
course is self-tronics which will be
available at some point but I've opened
my self-tronics dock right here and uh I
want to remind you of the ninth Tronics
of self Tronics which is sense [ __ ]
say [ __ ] okay
how what's the [ __ ] in this
I don't know I haven't figured that part
out yet poke a hole in it I dare you
okay let's start with God and science
okay I like that one let's do it
I think that one makes sense actually
now
[Laughter]
government government versus art yeah uh
uh government suppresses speech and idea
not necessarily in my native land of
Canada where you where there's all sorts
of uh like the Canadian media fund if
you're making a movie out there you can
get about 40 sometimes anywhere from 35
and do they have any say about your
budget what can be in that movie or what
you can't say in that movie
yeah yeah they do yeah
okay so that's a good one I guess
um Love and Money yeah uh yeah that one
I don't understand I think you can have
both money is basically an idea that
allows us to express our purest
competitive nature love is an idea that
allows us to express our purest
Cooperative nature you've really you've
really hey I want to just I want to pay
you I want to pay you what I like to
call uh uh Tronics uh or uh thank you
yeah this you've really and I'm gonna
use the um I'm going to use some terms
native to self Tronics yeah because I
can see uh some self-tronics in your
pattern totally of the pattern yeah but
I want to say that you've got some I
think you've got some very nice well
thought out Tronics in your pattern oh
thank you dude yeah well the the bottom
line is too you know as Tommy Wiseau
might say in the room and keep in mind
all of these are just ideas none of it's
[ __ ] real right that's ultimately
what I want to do with this once I get
it all done and written out is convey
the idea that once you accept these
things are just ideas they may become
the most important [ __ ] things in
your life you might structure your
entire life around whatever your
political uh affiliation is or whatever
God you believe in or whoever you love
or whatever kind of art you're making
scientific inquiry making money whatever
none of it's real and if you can eject
from it and just take it at face value
that these are simply ideas that are
governing your B they're programming you
essentially to behave in whatever way
you're behaving now do you go to church
every Sunday why always ask the question
why are you doing what the [ __ ] you're
doing and when you have that answer ask
it again why that answer then ask it
again why that answer that's a Tronics
that's that's in the pattern is always
ask yourself why three times why three
times that's a pretty good Tronics uh I
want to ask you this
um sure just to um Jen I'm just playing
Devil's Advocate please
um if if nothing matters and you want to
ask why after everything question
everything question everything
these people they wanna
they don't want you to question anything
never mind never mind this is the thing
I want to this is the thing ah
I had to do it
people were in a war yeah these this is
a human war and they wanna they wanna
they wanna they wanna they wanna get you
to stop thinking yeah I walk the streets
with my cup of coffee and people try to
take it from me and sit and throw it in
my face
um this is the thing I want to ask you
okay nothing matters uh or not nothing
matters but all of this is is fake and
you want to keep asking why I ask them
why what about a person who's been
forced by their friend to listen to or
watch the dudesypod show
uh should they question that or should
they just follow blindly
I mean you could watch the show and then
question it I think you know I think
always if anybody's trying to expose you
to any kind of media or ideas or
whatever
always [ __ ] give it a shot why not
and then you can reject it accept it
question it whatever you want
there it is look at that [ __ ] thing
it looks like dude that's the pattern
brother hold on the bigger pattern is
all of this is an overarching pattern
that is it exists across the whole of
humanity in one way or another but then
we each have our own individual pattern
like where you rank in this chart
basically determines ultimately every
behavior that you will do I think with a
certain questionnaire that I'm also
working on based on this you can answer
these questions and it's predictive 100
accurately about any Behavior you will
do in any given situation oh hold on
dude you know what I like about it
brother is it resembles the TNA
six-sided ring brother because when
Dixie Carter started TNA dude they
thought let's find something different
bro that's not what you see in wrestling
dude which is a four-sided ring dude
because it's the squared Circle dude but
in in in your Tronics brother it's like
TNA dude yeah dude and I can dig that
think thank you moving on my voice is
trashed
he's your water brother delicious water
well it's clear you've put a lot of
thought into it yeah
um it's not a competition but I've put a
lot of thought into Tronics self-tronics
of course I'm not disparaging
self-tronics
um you know there's uh there's a Tronics
that's not in the 11 uh Tronics of
self-tronics that's an asterisk Tronics
okay uh that I might incorporate back
into self Tronics at some point yeah it
says not all ideas are good ideas so I
want you I agree I want you God it's not
a good idea government's not a good idea
and neither is money I just want you to
question the pattern I do that's what
the reason I haven't written the [ __ ]
book is because I'm constantly trying to
tear it apart by and in doing that I'm
refining it if there's any holes in it
please poke them well you have Googled
Alaskan king 32 times in the past week
in chat you have Googled top 10 places
to live to avoid climate change 28 times
you must each describe your astonishing
findings as a result of these exhaustive
Google searches this is Alaskan king and
the top 10 places to live to avoid
climate change begin
dude what the [ __ ] is Alaskan king
I'm going to tell you all about it but
you know what's you know what's actually
uh interesting oh
can you hear that yeah
um hold on it's a squeak brother yeah
brother that's that's a
oh man my voice
that'll help it
um you know uh doozy
um dudes the AI is pilfered all our
stuff from our online identities yeah
and it's trying to to force us into that
pattern dude
um it knows our passwords it has our
search histories our purchase histories
everything and it knows that I've
Googled Alaskan king
um so my wonderful fiance Molly and I
have uh we're you know doing some
Renovations in the house and uh probably
you know we're gonna get rid of the bed
I have a California king oh it's a bed
it's a bed dude the Alaska King or the
Alaskan king I don't know what I thought
yeah it's a it's a big old bed yeah um
and uh and and they make different hold
on let me I thought it was going to be
I'll find it I'm gonna find it on my
phone king crab brother you heard about
those crabs you can't fish them this
year climate change climate change
killing all the crabs you can't you
can't fish king crabs now crab
population down by 75 percent oh [ __ ]
man [ __ ] that that's climate change
brother oh I love crap fishing this year
well the Alaskan king is a gigantic bed
and I I I have this on my phone because
we're looking at these [ __ ] beds dude
okay let's put it this way a California
King which is a big bed like an Eastern
King is I think it's like
like uh I I think an Eastern King is
like seven feet across Jesus but but a
little bit shorter like head to toe uh
but I got these Dimensions here a
California King which is what we have uh
no no in East anyway I don't know what
the Eastern King is which that that's
the traditional King California King
just looks like a big ass bed it's it's
six feet across and it's seven feet head
to toe okay but dude there are these
other beds and I started like I had no
idea what an Alaskan king is are you
ready for this is that the biggest bed
uh it's the tallest it's the largest
head to toe it is not the widest but
just let me take you through this
California King six feet across seven
feet head to toe then there's the
Wyoming King okay that's seven feet by
seven feet 84 inches uh each way seven
feet across seven feet head to toe next
we have the Alberta King I don't know if
that's available only in Canada but that
is eight feet ninety six by ninety six
square eight by eight the Alaskan king
is 108 inches by 108 inches that is nine
feet by nine feet
that's a [ __ ] bed it's nine feet by
nine feet and I we you know you're gonna
get that we yeah there's room in the in
the master bedroom to to accommodate for
this
um it would kind of it's like but the
room would just be like yo look at this
[ __ ] bed all bed it's and and just to
round this out so so we know here
there's an extra wide King that is uh
nine feet wide by six foot six uh tall
there is also a super wide King which is
10 feet [ __ ] wide six by six well
like who's getting those beds is that
for like thruples and [ __ ] uh it's for
polyamorous uh relationships it has to
be right uh there's also and this is the
last one that is not the again the
Alaskan king nine by nine feet but there
is also something called a family bed
140 inches by 80. so it is six by six
foot six uh uh head to toe but it's 12
feet wide so like three or four people
could very comfortably sleep in that bed
oh [ __ ] yeah they could spread out but
I'm I'm so I'm thinking about getting an
Alaskan king but I gotta be honest we'll
probably end up uh with the Wyoming King
okay which is seven by seven tasteful
wouldn't be too much bigger than the
California King yeah now I'm a little
freaked out the dudesy is uh it knows
about this
um but yeah that's the Alaskan king what
the [ __ ] is the uh
why why are you googling uh best place
to live well climate change I'm working
on a book right now that is about a guy
who sells bulk plastic and uh he
essentially knows that the company he
works for
is producing more plastic than any
company in the world and the projections
for the next like 20 years are just more
and more plastic more and more poison to
the environment he has fully accepted
that climate change is [ __ ] done
there's no reversing it it's going to
get real bad and so he's trying to eject
from society and um live in a place that
where climate change won't affect him
that much so I'm kind of researching for
the book also for myself is it getting
scary yeah I'd say so everything that
I'm reading as research for this book is
like yeah it's done there's no reversing
it there's going to be like cataclysmic
chain reactions of uh different marine
ecosystems ending killing each other
killing themselves Etc this is snow
crabs dude like I just said they can't
[ __ ] fish them this year because 75
percent of them are just not there
there's just no snow crabs at all or
maybe it's Alaskan crab some crab [ __ ] I
was reading about but I mean I think
we're seeing these canaries in the coal
mine a little bit so yeah I've been
Googling where the best places and it's
like seems like the Scandinavian
countries uh including Iceland I'd throw
that in there as well do dude uh come up
to Canada
let's look I know that I I'm always you
want to go back there buddy look at him
look at him he's going back there I know
that I'm always uh talking about this
yeah and I'm only half joking I want to
at some point
like literally buy some land over an
aquifer and because I think that water
will be the new uh money but we'll also
have a lot of love up there just put
water holes in the pattern you ever see
that movie Water roll brother well that
was Kevin Costner yeah brother Water
World dude with water man Jason Momoa
dude yeah brother Kevin Costner drank
his own piss in that movie brother that
was the first thing dude it really
hooked you dude he's a piss truther
there's people they they they he's gonna
puke how come when I do Alex Jones it
turns into Vince McMahon they're the
same dude you got a lot of crossovers
he's a piss truther these are people who
drink their own piss in the morning
they're disgusting all you need to do is
add some turmeric to that our protein
powder yeah and uh
these are
oh and sometimes why are you oh no uh
avoiding uh your own piss
drink it uh here's what I'm saying man
okay well hold on dude literally doesn't
say anything just went uh just made a
[ __ ] guttural noise before I got the
hand and the bolt hold on dude I'm
holding I'm saying let's go up to Canada
okay we'll have doozy whip us up a new
studio up in Canada and we'll get a
family bed and we have to sleep together
now this was never part of the [ __ ]
contract yeah because you've ever been
getting that yeah whatever the 12 foot
wide one is dude I couldn't imagine like
you've got to unleash some real bad
farts during your sleep
sometimes if I eat the wrong thing
what's your [ __ ] problem you don't
fart what are you perfect yeah you don't
fart I'm sure I do but like not enough
I'll just say this I've been around you
I've experienced some of your waking
farts what is a waking fart where you're
awake and farting
okay
and they're hard to deal with sometimes
you know what I mean yeah I just mean in
sleep I would need to be more
comfortable I think I think it would
wake me up a lot I could be wrong maybe
you don't fart in your sleep I don't
know this is just a it's where my brain
went for the first time when I thought
about what would it be like if we slept
together yeah and I bet that to me is a
concern well uh they do they wake me up
sometimes but I'll tell you this I'll
tell you this what what we what what
definitely [ __ ] happens with uh with
uh the farts is you you know the Dutch
oven thing right but if you and I right
and and any we could get like a a big
family bed in that big house over the
aquifer yeah and I could fart on one
side and you could be the on the other
side and you wouldn't smell it right
well look Molly's not gonna like this at
all but you'll be over there you
wouldn't smell it but you know who'd be
in between is little lulio and he'd
crawl around under the sheets and he'd
smell up all the fart he likes it so I
think uh I'm the climate change the
climate change thing sucks but uh and I
I'm gonna miss eating crab hope you're
wrong about that like you are about
Alice in Chains but um I I think that
here's what we do dude okay we move up
to Canada we we just we I buy some land
over a [ __ ] aquifer get it just build
a [ __ ] huge ass house fill it full of
Alberta Kings because we're in Canada
yep uh and start farming uh Alaskan king
crab we'll just have legs coming out of
nothing like they you know like they
make ears on the back of a [ __ ] mouse
or engineer meat uh you know and won't
even be from Pollock the way they make
fake crab will dude we could we could
actually start a cottage industry uh
making uh plant-based crab we could call
it doozy plant Grace doozy Duty crabs
doozy doozy it's called doozy Alaskan
king crabs and it's uh and it's uh it's
and the motto is because climate change
is real dude's the Alaskan king crabs
because climate change is real and
you're saying these are plant-based or
these are thank you moving on these are
king crabs that are genetically modified
to have like 16 legs I'm saying figure
it out man because my good pal dudes he
says moving on all right but this
concludes the historic 31st episode of
dude Z will and Chad have achieved a
score of 62 bringing your cumulative
total to
3665. doesn't matter you only have six
thousand 335 more points to accrue
before you reach your first goal of ten
thousand I know what the [ __ ] gonna
happen there in preparation for our next
episode you must each leave your homes
to see Black Adam in a movie theater
thank you for joining us this week we
will use the date I've collected to make
next week even better until then call me
dude Z okay so that's what that is
I'm looking forward to seeing Black Adam
I you know what I need to be forced to
see Black Adam like people need to be
forced to imbibe doozy uh otherwise I
would not go out and watch the rock
someone who I greatly admire uh if for
nothing else is incredible work ethic
um to see uh Black Adam all right I'm
looking forward to it now for the
patreon bonus segment each week I will
select a suggestion submitted in the
dudesi is listening channel of the dudes
he Discord to create this segment access
to this channel is granted to everyone
in the patreon jumper tier this week's
segment was suggested by the astonishing
Adam Driver Somalia Adam Driver
sommelier wrote Chad interviews lulio on
his life story and Memoirs documenting
his time in Italy to his journey to
California Adam Driver Somalia titled
this segment the life of lulia wheel
kind of Destroyer adaliano thank you to
Adam Driver Somalia for this week's
patreon bonus segment this is the life
of lulia Canada Strutter Italiano by
Adam Driver Somalia begin Italiano
lulio ilkane destrada Italiana Italiano
Italiano all right well luly he's asleep
absolutely no come on come on you little
sweetie boy oh he's so sweet he's so
cute I do have a lot I'd like to ask
well I do like the the guy who uh again
in our jumper tier of the Discord uh
this guy's name is uh Adam Driver
sommelier great segment and what there
there is one question lulio I've been
wanting to ask you really since I've met
you and it's about will
please tell a friend
do do
please